Hola bienvenida Sara Castro directora de
deportes de Caracol radio y del diario
as Colombia Sara Muchísimas gracias por
estar acá con nosotros Hola Omar como
siempre Un gusto A ver comenzamos
hablando del Napoli no se pudo en el
estadio Diego Armando Maradona que ya
tenía la fiesta servida pero
independientemente de dónde se produzca
parece cuestión de tiempo para que caiga
ese descuento No sí la fiesta se aplaza
pero que habrá fiesta habrá fiesta esos
18 puntos en seis jornadas creo que son
suficientes para un equipo como el de
espalético ha mostrado una solidez un
estilo de juego contundente y con unas
figuras que sin duda han llamado la
atención en el fútbol europeo por
supuesto esto es histórico y hace parte
de esa épica que acompaña al Napoli no
hay que olvidar que el último título fue
en 1990 con Diego Armando Maradona en
sus filas y de hecho el otro escudeto
también lo ganó en 1986 de la mano de
Maradona hoy sale rentar a plantó un
partido
de esos que para hacer historia también
ellos yo creo que ellos querían quedarse
con la satisfacción de hacer un juego
muy completo plantearon un bloque
defensivo muy sólido un 541 con Memo
Ochoa además el mexicano como gran
figura del equipo visitante Así que creo
que espagueti tendrá que esperar algunos
días junto a su equipo pero sin duda ese
título está consumado para el Napoli que
sin duda histórico para para el fútbol
italiano pasamos a Alemania el Bayer
llevaba cuatro partidos seguidos sin
ganar Ahora te pregunto tendrá
consistencia suficiente para mantener
esta ventaja Que de momento es de un
punto sobre el dortmund Omar yo siento
que sí siento que el dortmund no ha
aprovechado justamente esos momentos en
los que el Bayern Munich no ha podido
encontrar esa solidez Y esa solidez
viene Pues de una crisis institucional
que ya se viene hablando en el fútbol
alemán primero con la salida de
nagelsman de una manera que no fue no
fue normal no fue digamos acorde a esos
valores que suele tener el Bayern Munich
a la hora de elegir o
a sus entrenadores y tú él llegó en un
momento en el que tenía que encontrarse
con una serie de Champions League
bastante complicada por supuesto pero
creo que de aquí en adelante y a partir
de un partido o de una fecha como la de
hoy en la que el dortmund no supo
aprovechar ese momento
el Bayern puede quedarse con esta liga
así que pues un punto de ventaja es muy
poco pero siento que el Bayern Munich
después de 11 ligas consecutivas ganadas
y no estando esas figuras como las tuvo
Club en su momento cuando se ganan los
títulos de 2010 creo que esta liga va a
ser para el Bayern Munich y hablando Ya
de la Premier League la preguntaba en
torno a un Arsenal que parece ir en
picada se puede pensar en una retoma de
la cima ante una Manchester City que
está en una forma en un momento estelar
Pues ojalá ojalá yo creo que aquí en
este espacio hemos hemos hablado mucho
de lo que significa
esta cuarta temporada de arteta al
frente del Arsenal lo que estaba
consiguiendo después de consolidar una
idea y un equipo sin embargo las curvas
de rendimiento de los de los clubes son
así no se encuentran con con momentos en
los que el rendimiento no es el mejor y
ese partido de mitad de semana en el que
se enfrentaban tanto Arsenal como
Manchester City creo que esa caída tanto
emocionalmente como futbolísticamente
puede complicar Qué es lo que tiene que
gestionar ahora el equipo de Guardiola
la competencia ellos aún están pensando
en la Champions League tiene un una
llave muy complicada ante el Real Madrid
así que sin duda eso y Las bajas físicas
ya estamos hablando que de bruyne no se
sabe cuánto tiempo estará fuera de las
canchas por una molestia que tenía eso
es lo que puede complicar al City no
tener que enfocarse en conservar a los
jugadores que necesita sobre todo para
conseguir Este título de Champions que
es lo que se le pide a Pep Guardiola el
rendimiento de City viene siendo pues
indiscutible es un equipo absolutamente
sólido un equipo que con las variantes
que ha logrado hacer en los últimos
tiempos manteniendo los conceptos
básicos de Pep Guardiola pues es
indomable casi que en cualquier lugar
menos en esta Champions que tendrá que
enfrentarse al equipo de ance